if you're struggling with your diet just
can't sustain those healthy eating
habits you're not alone
might i suggest the plant power meal
planner our digital toolbox of unlimited
access to thousands of customizable
plant-based recipes
integrated with grocery delivery expert
support seven days a week
and so much more all for just a dollar
ninety a week to learn more and sign up
visit meals.richroll.com do it now
okay let's do the show
i moved to america when i was 25 and i
just left everything behind and i came
with two suitcases and i barely spoke
the language
but it is such a liberating feeling
to know that everything you need is
inside of you
you don't need anything else and
i mean only covet could have given me
this experience
again so late in life at 44 years old
where i was literally sitting in my
apartment a year ago
not knowing if i'm gonna have a
restaurant not knowing how to
pay for the bills for the business
and coming to terms with
the idea i might lose it all
and it's okay and when you get to that
place
and i hope i don't need to get
physically to that place
again but i hope mentally i can get
myself into that space
for many many years to come because in
that space
you're very free and you're able to make
pretty bold moves
without fear that's daniel hume
and this is the ritual podcast
the ritual podcast
okay so what happens when one of if not
the greatest restaurants in the world
suddenly seemingly out of the blue
goes 100 plant-based
well for perspective in context of the
132
three-star michelin restaurants around
the world
not a single one is vegan
so with that most would say such a move
is tantamount to financial suicide
but daniel whom the world-renowned chef
and owner of 11 madison park
sees it differently he sees it as
purpose-driven mission-based and the
greatest creative challenge
of his lifetime a native of switzerland
a former pro cyclist
and a 251 marathoner daniel started
cooking at 14
preparing exquisite meals in some of the
finest swiss hotels and restaurants
before earning his first michelin star
at the age of 24.
in 2003 he moved to the u.s to become
the executive chef at campton place in
san francisco
where he received four stars from the
san francisco chronicle
three years later recruited by danny
meyer
daniel moves to new york and becomes the
executive chef at 11 madison park and he
revitalizes this restaurant so
completely that in 2017
it was named number one on the coveted
list of the world's 50 best restaurants
that's all amazing of course but the
story really gets interesting when the
pandemic hits
like most restaurants 11 madison park
closed its doors they did that for
almost a year
and teetered on bankruptcy but it was
during this time that daniel
like many of us started thinking more
deeply
about things like purpose what he stands
for
and how he could leverage this talent of
his and
the resources at his disposal to
more meaningfully participate in
solutions to things like food insecurity
the ills of animal agriculture and more
broadly
the inherent unsustainable nature of
food systems
in a moment of clarity he decides to
make this
crazy bold change first by converting
his kitchen
into a commissary and kitting out a food
truck to provide free meals to food
insecure new yorkers
he partners with this organization this
non-profit called rethink food
which is committed to creating
sustainable and equitable
food systems solutions at scale and
finally
upon emp's recent reopening
turns the most revered restaurant in the
world
plant-based a restaurant where every
meal enjoyed pays for five meals freely
provided to those in need
and that decision when announced was
like this
bombshell sending the food world into a
frenzy
but daniel's bet is paying off within
hours of the announcement 11 madison
park booked a full month of reservations
and today
just five weeks later the waitlist
exceeds
15 000 people brevity is not the soul of
my wit
today i've got much more to say about
the amazing conversation to come
but first okay daniel
so this is what went down the day that
11 madison park announced its new menu
which was covered extensively in the
media
i knew i immediately wanted to get
daniel on the show as soon as possible
because my newsfeed was blowing up with
people commenting about this
incredible story and my friend past
podcast guest
former food and drinks editor for
esquire jeff gordanir
who had profiled daniel for esquire in
the new york times
connected us daniel agreed to do the
show
but he made that agreement on one
condition that i first
dine at 11 madison park and i'm not one
to say no to that so i
immediately booked my flight to new york
city i joined jeff for said dinner
which was i don't even know how to
describe it it was exquisite it was
divine
it was like this performance art unlike
anything i had previously
experienced a admittedly rare
privilege and the following day i sat
down with daniel for the conversation
you're about to enjoy
it's a conversation about why food at
this level
food as curated experience food is art
is important it's about what makes a
great chef
a great restaurant great in the first
place
and it's about what it really means to
pursue
a passion it's also about constant
reinvention but more than anything
this is a conversation about personal
evolution
the search for meaning and purpose
beyond
accolades and what it means to mature
your career and devote your talents
into something mission based in service
to
a better world daniel is remarkable his
story is wildly fascinating
and i don't feel it's an overstatement
to say that
he is now one of the most important
figures in the plant-based movement
i believe 11 madison park because
of its stature because of what this move
represents and
because of what daniel imagined and is
now creating
is well poised to forever change the
restaurant industry and
also how people think about what
plant-based cuisine
is and can be it was an honor
to experience his talents it was an
honor to spend time with him and it's an
honor to share our exchange with you
so without further ado this is me and
one of if not the
best chefs in the world daniel whom
all right we're good to do this how you
doing thanks for doing this today
i'm good yeah i'm so happy to be here
yeah oh that's very very sweet of you to
say
um i am thrilled to be talking to you
today
thank you for making the time and thank
you for
making room for me at the restaurant
last night jeff gordnier and i
had an exquisite meal curated by you and
your wonderful staff it's a
memory uh that i won't soon forget and
it was really quite something i have so
many
takeaways from the experience
not the least of which is coming into
this
realization that you
as the chef and like the team leader
of course the centerpiece of this
experience is the food
but there's so much more that goes into
curating
this experience you have to be this
gregarious host
you have to be present with all of the
patrons despite whatever chaos is going
on in the kitchen
and i noticed an extraordinary
equanimity
in your disposition as you greeted
everybody and spent time
with each of you know the patrons that
had you know i'm sure looked forward to
this experience
and it really um belies the trope of the
screaming chef
and you know the chaos and anarchy
that we've come to sort of believe to be
the uh the rule as opposed to the
exception i know you had your moments in
the past with that kind of behavior but
i didn't see any indication of that last
night
no i think you know when you i think
when you lose your cool
as a chef it is a weakness
and um i mean we've all been in this
situation
we as chefs have all been in these
situations
where we lose our cool or where we're in
an environment where other people
are losing their cool but it is really a
weakness
of the organization of the restaurant
and you know today i think kitchens are
far
uh far from that and especially ours i
mean it's
pretty well oiled machine and we have so
many talented people so there's really
no need
for that kind of behavior right if you
have your management structure
sorted out and you are being an
effective leader
you know from kind of a military
perspective then there shouldn't be
those problems right if you're resorting
to that kind of behavior it means
there's
something broken in that chain of
command right that's exactly right
yeah that's exactly and and you know in
fact it's a shame
that there are tv shows um
you know portraying that kind of
behavior
because it's really not how it is it's
not
yeah no you had you you used to do a
little bit of that though right back in
the day
i mean you know what is really difficult
um
is when you're a young chef
to to get to the top or to be recognized
you have to do it with a lot less
resources than with with the people
you're competing with
like today we have you know we it cost a
certain amount to eat at the restaurant
yeah um you know people from all over
the world want to
work with me um so we we have so much
going for us but when you're young and
you know the meal can't be that
expensive
no one knows who you are so you're
working with
you know just whoever you find and it's
kind of like a smoking mirror
kind of situation yeah to to rise up
up the ranks yeah and and and so it's
just a lot of pressure
on on the individual who is trying to
make sure
i want to get into the reinvention the
reimagination of food
all the exciting developments that are
taking place at 11 madison park but
before we do that
i think it would be cool to spend a few
minutes just talking about the
importance of cuisine
in general and just by way of personal
background i'm a pretty
simple guy i'm a rice and beans and
guacamole dude like i eat
popper food i've been plant-based for a
long time yeah my
tastes are not that refined i have had
privileged experiences
a couple of eating at fine
establishments yours being
certainly you know one of them i ate at
noma two years ago with jeff
i've eaten at larpesh so i've had those
experiences but i wouldn't consider
myself
like a gastronomist by any stretch of
the imagination so
and and i think it's important to say
like most people
in their lives will never have the
privilege
of dining at your restaurant or a
similar
analogous type situation so
why like why is
cuisine at this level important like how
do you think about
food as art at the highest level and the
impact that that has and the meaning
that that carries
throughout culture well i think it's
an art form i've always cooked
in those restaurants uh from the
beginning of my career
i worked in these mishna store
restaurants and for me the way
i've i've experienced it was was as a as
a performance
uh and and as an art form and it's
very much um tied to culture
culture of the place like when you're
working in a restaurant in france or
in italy or in south america
those experiences are very much
different
they're very much tied to the place and
they're making references to
to the culture um and and of course
coming
uh i i grew up in switzerland and um
fine dining for us was coming out of
france which is maybe even the
birthplace of
that kind of dining um i think there's a
beautiful culture tied to it
um and it starts from you know the
farmers
um the artisans who make
the ceramics and the silverware and the
glass blowing
and then it's the people who make the
linens and then of course
uh the team that works the floor and the
way they move through the dining room
and then of course the chefs and then
the recipes they're
inspired by um that go way back
sometimes
um so i i think it's uh and i
struggled with this um many times in my
life
with the idea of how much it costs to
eat at one of those restaurants
because food is so magical on so many
levels
and food touches everyone and to cook
for
an audience you know of the one percent
that can be challenging sometimes um
but through the pandemic
somehow i found a whole new meaning
in all of it like our restaurant shut
down yeah
march 16th of last year
and um all we have left was an empty
space
farmers with so much um
food that was going bad and food
insecurity that was
you know doubling and so we transformed
11 madison park into a community kitchen
yeah so you go from in 2017 the
restaurants rated
the number one restaurant in the world
on that coveted
50 world's best list i'm sure with that
there's pressure to
continue what you're doing the way that
you're doing it it's obviously working
and it's
attracting people from all over the
world and you're being allotted for it
and you're getting all this attention
2020 hits you're forced to close the
restaurant you're facing
bankruptcy you make some interesting
pivots during the pandemic year but in
2021
you open as a 100 plant-based restaurant
none of the other
of the 132 three-star restaurants are
vegan i mean that requires
immense balls to make such a bold move
but reinvention is really
the touchstone of everything that you've
done historically throughout not just
your career but
your life like you're constantly
pivoting and iterating
and challenging yourself to do something
fresh and new
i think it's one part for selfish
reasons to keep myself
interested in it um because i i don't
see myself doing the same thing
um over and over again and especially
after experiencing the pandemic
i definitely didn't want to go back to
to doing what we did before
yeah it seems like it's a it's a bit of
a a reckoning i mean
i think in the sort of hoity-toity high
altitude of
cuisine at this level there's a lot of
discussion and dialogue about things
that are important within that
subculture but actually don't really
matter
you know they're nice they're ego
inflating etc
but the pandemic my sense is that it
really compelled you
to kind of confront your your your path
in a very existential way and it
provided you
this opportunity to reimagine and infuse
your talent and everything that you do
with this extraordinary you know
mission-based
level of purpose and intention that can
help
people beyond the very few who can
experience the food at 11 madison park
no for sure and you know in 2017 when
when we became number one it was
actually not such a great it wasn't as
great as one would imagine that feeling
it was actually coming with a with a lot
of
emptiness and and maybe it has to do
that
this was a goal that we were chasing for
so long
you know probably for 10 years that that
number one spot was sort of our
carrot that we were chasing and and
you've done
you know uh marathons and triathlons and
sometimes
when you train a lot for an event and
then you have the event and you're on
such a high
you you can kind of fall into a hole a
little bit while you're a little
depressed
yeah and i think that's definitely what
happened to me
um after becoming number one and i was
looking for more meaning
i was looking for a higher purpose and
and then the pandemic hit and sort of
i i realized that my language
is is food is cooking and
actually food is um you know
food is part of everyone's lives but
food is so central to so many problems
we're facing
uh on this planet food insecurity being
one
you know global warming uh and and
and farming and and and so much more and
and so
i i found myself in this spot of having
this kind of incredible opportunity
to actually say something through the
food
to show a delicious way um to cooking
with only plants and and feeling that
that could make a real difference
the precursor to this is this decision
to open up
11 madison park as a commissary kitchen
and start providing
meals to the food insecure right and
doing that in partnership with
rethink which was founded by one of your
former cooks yeah right so walk me
through
that chapter yeah so one of our cooks
three years before the pandemic who
worked with us
he said hey i see you're having all
these
leftovers or these parts of like you
know we're only using the top part of a
broccoli and the stem we don't use and
and and that is true to so many other
ingredients
and he said what if i would take all
these ingredients and if i would have a
little commissary kitchen
and i would make meals out of these
ingredients
for people in need would you be able to
support me
so we founded together this organization
called rethink food
that was relying on restaurants
supplying them
with their leftovers and we did that and
that was you know it was successful but
it was limited of how many
meals we could really do but then the
pandemic hit
and obviously all the restaurants closed
and so
the supply to our commissary kitchens to
prepare these meals also stopped
and i just found myself in this position
where i
had this organization rethink where i
had an
empty kitchen a massive professional
empty kitchen
where i knew a lot of cooks without jobs
and where i knew all the farmers and
producers
sitting on food that they're not selling
anymore now
and so we realized that we had to change
what rethink was
and we sort of started this program
called rethink certified
and we allowed other restaurants any
restaurant
to use their kitchen and their staff and
their farmers
to produce these meals and we as
rieslink
organization uh are buying these meals
from the restaurants so actually
restaurants were able to keep
people employed farmers were
able to keep supplying foods
and and people were getting fed right um
so that was a really pivotal moment
uh changed the rethink organization
but also changed my belief of
cooking for the one percent yeah because
cooking for the one percent
allowed me to have this voice
to be able to raise the funds we needed
to be able to get other people on board
and so i promised myself that if i would
reopen 11 madison park
it would have to have a higher purpose
so today with every guest um that comes
to our restaurant
we feed five people forward we actually
started a food truck
um the 11 madison truck in partnership
with the rethink
where we have a hundred guests a night
we give 500 meals per day away for free
in communities of need
we cook the food in our own restaurant
our staff that also cooks the fancy
meals
and then our dining room crew that
serves our guests in the restaurant
also go out into these neighborhoods and
delivering these meals so it's sort of
like a circular
economy right right right the problem
of food insecurity and the problem of
food waste
dovetail because the solution to one
to the former can be found in the latter
in so many ways and we are in this
extraordinary predicament where you know
more than 50 million people lack
reliable access to nutritious meals
70 tons of good food goes underutilized
every year
if you talk to paul hawkin who wrote
drawdown he will tell you that food
waste
is one of the biggest contributors to
climate change
solving this problem in your local
community is one thing
scaling it in order to address
the larger national and sort of
international issues
that relate to this is another thing but
i think what's interesting about trying
to solve this problem grappling with the
solution
orients itself around communication and
distribution
it's not you know food insecurity isn't
by dent of lack of food
it's related to ineffectual distribution
of the food that gets wasted in so many
restaurants and
homes every single day right but
to go to a busy chef or a busy
restaurant and layer on top of
you know their impossible schedule the
idea that they have to prepare meals or
set aside you know it's like
you're creating a situation that's
probably not gonna work right so
what i understand about rethink is
training chefs and restaurants
and creating systems through technology
and effective communication tools that
allow it to be
seamless so it doesn't create a burden
on these restaurants it just becomes
part of how they operate is that fair
no i mean what you're saying is is
absolutely accurate
it's about communication and there
is enough food for everyone and that's
what's so heartbreaking it
is actually a problem we can solve there
is actually enough food
and um you know the restaurant business
is not the most lucrative business to be
in
and actually the goal of rethink is
actually that it's a benefit
to the restaurant to get on board to be
a breathing certified restaurant
yeah so talk about that a little bit
it's sort of like leed certification for
restaurants and i think it plays into
this idea
that especially amongst younger people
purpose-driven companies organizations
are are really crucial in consumers
making conscious choices about the
companies and the businesses that they
choose to patronize
yeah for me really the light bulb went
off
right as the pandemic started and i
decided
that we would start cooking these meals
i i went to
different soup kitchens around the city
to learn as much as i could
how they were operating and you know how
meals are packaged and what were the
meals
consist of and what what gets good
feedback and whatnot
and i realized that all these soup
kitchens
were run by volunteers and
a lot of them weren't as well organized
they also didn't have the connection
that we have
to to producers and farmers and so when
we started producing these meals
i was shocked how efficient we were we
were able to produce 5000 meals a day
pretty quickly
um that's a lot of meals we were
efficient in time we were efficient at
price too
you know we were set we were told that a
meal is probably five dollars per meal
and within a week our meals were like
around two dollars
so then i realized that every restaurant
produces waste as well like you said
and i realized that the chefs and the
restaurant have a responsibility
and are in the center of this
conversation because we're talking to
farms every day we're producing waste
every day we have
talented cooks talented team members
so the efficiencies in a restaurant are
far greater than
in in commissary kitchens and then
restaurants also struggle
often to pay you know their rent and
their staff
and so forth and so if the organization
is already paying soup kitchens they
might as well pay restaurants
so there is actually a great benefit
yeah it gives them a base
level of predictability in their income
that can create like almost like
uh universal basic income for
restaurants right as long as they're
providing this service
they know they can pay a certain
percentage of their bills and keep the
lights on
regardless of how many people show up
every day yeah that was exactly the idea
you know it helps for pay for the rent
it's says it's a consistent income
um no one knows better than chefs how to
cook
delicious inexpensive meals yeah you
were
sharing last night a little bit about
the
impact of visiting these various
neighborhoods around
new york city and really being boots on
the ground
and developing a greater appreciation
and understanding for
how most people struggle every single
day to get access to
nutritious food so talk a little bit
about that experience
yeah i mean it's shocking and it's
unacceptable that in a city like new
york city
that kind of poverty and not
accessibility to food
uh is is a reality
i mean yesterday i went to visit
the queensbridge housing project because
i'm really
interested in you know we
me as 11 madison park we can't change
the entire world but we got to start
somewhere so i'm really trying to figure
out
where would it be the most meaningful so
i've been visiting
different community centers uh different
community leaders i mean the one thing
that that is so incredible you know and
there are so many bad neighborhoods
in new york and all over the country but
even as bad as they are there are always
these angels these incredible people
who are doing good who are helping
others and sometimes you wonder wow
where do they take this energy from but
it's just so beautiful
and that has been consistent in wherever
i have visited yeah
and yesterday in queensbridge i mean
this is a
six block radius um
you know square that has 69
apartment buildings that houses you know
12
000 people and um
you know there's one little grocery
store where the fresh food section
is one little corner i mean just
unbelievable
there is no access to fresh food and
it's 20 minutes from here we're in
downtown manhattan
yeah yeah so the solution rests
and i mean you can you can deliver meals
you can deliver food to these
communities
but that's akin to a band-aid in the
sense that
rather than teaching them how to fish
you're providing a fish right so the
the the long-term solution rests in
empowering these
remarkable people in the communities
these catalysts these
lightning rods for change and providing
them with the access and the
tools that they require to empower their
own neighborhoods right and
so much of that i think can begin with
teaching people how to grow their own
food and leveraging
all of the rooftops across you know
manhattan and other urban areas across
the country in the world to
basically connect more deeply with the
nutritious foods that they so
desperately need
yeah no you're absolutely right and
that's what we're learning
as well you know having this food truck
in these neighborhoods
it is just like an antenna to gather
information
and um it it is although every meal
really matters and people really
rely on it it is a band-aid
and the problems obviously go much
deeper
so we're really trying to figure out
next steps and one thing that we're in
the process of is there's all this
you know in next to uh queen's bridge
housing project there are all these
buildings
yeah with empty roofs and uh
so we actually secured a four acre
uh space where we
are in the process of building a rooftop
farm
and hopefully you know create a farmer's
market
for you know the housing projects
where people can use their food stamps
and prices are reasonable
and then also have an educational
program
what's so beautiful about our industry
the restaurant industry is that
this is a great place for people to come
to
who you know didn't finish
their schooling or you know need a
second chance
or or even coming from a broken home
um the restaurant industry really allows
for people to
to excel if they bring passion uh
to the work on a daily basis
apprenticeship
type career pass that still exists
you're right it's it's a beautiful
industry
and many of us needed you know i've yeah
i didn't finish 14
we're going to get into that like left
home at 15. it's bananas
right and look at you so there are many
of us who
who found sort of a home and and family
in a way too
in our industry so i'm very hopeful that
you know we can
attract some some talent from some of
these neighborhoods
um also you know our industry is not the
most diverse
which which is an issue and and i'm i'm
also very much
thinking about that and it's like why is
that because it doesn't actually make
sense
at all i promise you we'll be right back
but
let's talk for a minute just a minute
about hiring
i run a small business over here and uh
let me tell you something i'm sure you
already know this but
hiring is hard it's really hard
so hard that i've learned the hard way
it's also time consuming it's imperfect
all great reasons you gotta check out
indeed which
is the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple
just attract interview and hire in fact
with indeed
you can do all of your hiring in one
place even the interviewing part
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter
indeed instant match helps you make a
short list of great candidates fast
the moment you sponsor a job you get a
list of quality candidates whose resumes
on indeed
match your job description you can then
invite them
to apply right then right there
plus indeed makes finding quality
candidates even faster with 135
assessments to help make sure
you find applicants with the right
skills indeed is the number one source
of hires in the u.s
helps you hire great people fast best of
all you only pay for applicants who meet
your must-have
qualifications so get started right now
with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post
at indeed.com slash rich roll
get a 75 credit at indeed.com
rich roll indeed dot com
slash rich roll offer valid through
september 30th
terms and conditions apply and finally
we're brought to you today by
whoop whoop you heard me right
you count calories you might maybe you
should
do you evaluate your macros do you track
your run pace with extreme precision
sure you can do all that stuff but what
about all those hidden
invisible things going on inside your
body things you
can't sense or intuit things like heart
rate variability
or metabolic rate that are crucial data
points in
understanding fully understanding how
your body is dealing with stress
and strain if you indeed want to truly
understand what goes into maintaining a
consistently high level of output
you got to do what i did and pick
yourself up a whoop
which is basically the stylish very
stylish fitness tracker you might have
seen on my left wrist that
communicates personalized insights
through their app that actually lets you
know
how much sleep you need each day how
recovered your body is to take on the
day
and how strenuous your day was from
everything you did
in and outside of training in the last
24.
whoops sleep recommendations have been
key to the way i structure my day
and i appreciate that woop tracks all
things sleep from
your sleep cycles the stages the
disturbances the efficiency
all of which is fascinating and super
informative
so if you're looking to be smarter about
how you sleep recover and train so
you too can be your best you got to
check out whoop and right now for you
guys my listeners woop is offering 15
off when you use the code rich roll at
checkout go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p dot com and use the
code rich role at checkout
to save 15 off your order unlock your
best self
today okay
back to the show
let's talk about the pivot to taking 11
madison park plant-based
it's one thing to do rethink and deliver
all these meals and be part of the
solution of addressing food insecurity
how does that relate to
this you know basically maverick in the
food world decision
to drastically alter your menu and go
100
plant-based yeah i think you know the
pandemic definitely gave us
all time to kind of uh take a step back
and
think about everything rethink
uh everything um and uh
i sort of thought about you know what
was really important to me and
and what were the things that got me to
this place and what got 11 madison park
uh to this place and um
one of our one of my main inspirations
is miles davis
um who has been an inspiration for uh
over 15 years and it kind of happened by
accident
but it was in an early early review
right a review
said more more miles more money you have
to figure out what that meant
so we came up with the list of 11 words
that were most commonly used to describe
him
among the words uh cool endless
reinvention forward moving light
innovative and so forth is that the
plaque that's in the kitchen
exactly exactly i was wondering where
those words derive from
and they became kind of our mission
statement and
two of those words endless reinvention
and forward moving and just thinking
about miles and
and he has been such a deep inspiration
and it's been part of
the success of of of the restaurant so
what does this mean today endless
reinvention and forward moving it
obviously means we have to change right
it's like dylan going electric
yeah or miles going electric when he did
pitches yeah yeah
um but you know if i'm
considered an expert in food
if i'm truly at the forefront of dining
and if 11 madison park is truly like one
of the best restaurants in the world
you know that as a chef i've been
cooking for 35
years i've seen
products disappear i've seen the quality
of products change
um you know and some of the luxurious
products
even more so and you know we are a
luxury brand
that's just what it is when i think
about caviar for example
and i think about that we are still
celebrating that
as a luxurious product that is an old
idea
because caviar isn't wild anymore
caviar is not rare it's plentiful you
can find it everywhere you can buy
caviar at the airport
and it doesn't even taste that good
anymore mm-hmm it's all farm-raised now
right
it's all farm-raised and and we're still
holding on to this idea that this is one
of the most luxurious product
that idea is broken and so if i'm that
expert
and i'm continued and i've been guilty
for it as well because we've still
celebrated caviar
when we already knew this but coming out
of the pandemic
and i think part of the issue is that
this is not just some artistic endeavor
this is our lives this is how we make
our money
and we need guests and so
11 madison park is selling an experience
it's actually quite unique to other
restaurants
and during the pandemic i think that
became clear to me that
what we're actually selling is not the
food that's on the plate
it's actually more like a broadway show
ticket
and so we have the unique opportunity
to change people's
ideas and thoughts and what they think
luxury is
and i think
my ambition was to create the meal
that was as magical as luxurious as
delicious
as a meal was before but without using
any
animal products and if we could do this
then maybe in a few years
a restaurant can charge more for a
carrot
main course or which today you know you
still have to deal with
the cost of the staff and the cost of
the rent and
and if you can only charge twenty
dollars for a main course because
it's only plant-based it's specifically
yeah sure
yeah i i mean a couple of reflections on
that first of all
you know change requires change at the
top and change at the
at the bottom in other words you need
grassroots
groundswell populist change boots on the
ground
but you also have to at the highest
level set the tone
for the rest of the culture and you
being in this privileged position
where the decisions that you make and
the menu that you arrive upon
has influence and impact across the food
world and then trickles down
into culture like the power of that is
huge to
shift mindsets change perceptions
and create new trends if he can do this
and be so successful i know when
you made the announcement and you know
there's the food world just
exploded with a million hot takes on
whether this was a good idea or not
um but here we are you're only like a
month into
the reopening and you've got a waitlist
of 15 000 people i mean the people have
spoken
this is something people are very
interested in it's successful
and what does that mean in terms of how
people
are are rethinking for themselves
what great food can be and how we can
tie
great food to meaning and purpose in our
own lives to forge the the future of our
imagination for
the generations to come and that's a
beautiful thing and at the same time
secondly this idea of creating an
experience you know i
i experienced it last night it's
unbelievable like everybody knows your
name the minute you walk
in jeff had a an umbrella the umbrella
was taken he
there's no there's no claim check you
know and then when we left
they remembered and jeff was telling me
stories about
the dreamweavers and the magicians and
all these iterations of the restaurant
over the years i mean you used to have a
couple people kind of wandering
anonymously the floor semi eavesdropping
on people and when
somebody would say oh wouldn't it be
great if we had this or
it's a bummer that our tropical vacation
got canceled that suddenly you would
materialize this experience for people
like magic which is unbelievable
to create that kind of experience for
your guests
yeah it's a really special place and it
it has gone
through a lot of different iterations
and it has constantly
uh evolved and and moved forward but it
was always very much
about the gas creating these magical
moments for the guests and now
i think you know it used to at some
point the money was all about new york
and
and about all the artisans of new york
and the products of new york and
of course many other chefs have
championed
being local but i think today local
isn't enough anymore and uh so we need
to know
we need to show a delicious way uh a
luxurious way in
in a different way i i compared a little
bit to
you know when you look at the car
industry and you see
uh when toyota prius came out with the
hybrid car
i think it's more than 20 years ago that
was such a groundbreaking and
incredible move and idea
and uh but but it wasn't the most sexy
car
and and and that's why it didn't really
get the big traction at that time and uh
and and it was really when tesla started
making luxurious
electric cars that now the entire car
industry
uh is transitioning so and that's from
the top down
if elon had introduced the first tesla
as an economy vehicle i'm not sure it
would have worked his first car
was like a 250 000 roadster
yeah and they only produced a few so the
idea being
create an aspirational brand you come
out with the luxury product
first over time with scale you can
create
products that consumers can get more
accessibly
yeah i think that's exactly that was my
thought a little bit
that that could have a massive massive
massive impact
yeah because we are going there actually
right
so talk about that i mean we still
haven't gotten down to the nitty-gritty
of like
why 100 plant-based can you have a
little fish why don't you know why
is there a little little bit of me like
why are you so ardently
doing this you know in this rigorous way
as somebody who's been plant-based for
15 years i get it i'm just interested in
like
you're how you think about that for
yourself well for
for us it was just exciting uh one part
it was
exciting to challenge ourselves to that
kind of level like in the
in the beginning it seemed so daunting
to let go
[Music]
of all these ingredients that we worked
with for so many years and even
ingredients that made our restaurant
famous yeah i mean we perfected
cooking the lobster and the duck yeah
like very rich food
yeah mostly rich food but um
what i've learned is that by
letting go of these things today i feel
so liberated in a way that i never
thought was possible
as a chef i'm more excited than i've
ever been
and i feel my palate of ingredients has
only grown because before in a way
we were stuck with these things you had
to have lobster
you had to have the duck you had to have
a foie gras
and and today we're rewriting
an entire new language
it's not clear what the main course is
going to be or the appetizer it's like
the range of
ingredients yeah it's creatively
inspired i think there is something
to this idea of constraints
driving innovation in the way that
and if an artist is restricted in their
color palette or
a movie director is suddenly you know
suddenly facing budget cuts like those
can
oh we don't have 65 days to shoot this
movie we only have 28 and we're not
going to be able to get this or that and
you're forced
within those constraints to come up with
solutions and
so often those solutions end up pushing
the art
forward in ways that wouldn't have been
possible without those constraints so
there is something about those
boundaries i think that
really force you to dig deeper
into your talent and come up with
something new and that's how we move
culture forward yes i mean we're not
anti-meat but we are pro-planet i think
that's
one thing and and if we can prove a way
that you can be completely without like
for example
we feel like we've been working in food
our whole lives
and we're very creative with it and
where we apply our creativity
we want to prove a way to do it without
animal products
if someone orders a cappuccino
at the end of their meal we're not going
to lecture you
what kind of milk you should drink we'll
have plenty of plant-based milks
but we'll also have the cow milk because
our
we're not the food police breaking my
heart i know i'm sorry
but you made the most unreal
sunflower butter last night and those
those rolls were extraordinary i can't
believe there wasn't dairy in those
i have to imagine that you could
innovate
in the plant-based milk space to come up
with something that would
soothe the palate and disabuse people of
this idea that
it has to be dairy in their cappuccino
we're definitely working
you know on all those kind of things
but we want to lift people up to
come because most of our guests
are not sure it's not it's not a vegan
restaurant for vegans
no no all the the fancy vegan people are
going to come i know they have been
coming yes
um but that's not really the intention
here the intention is to to change
people's ideas
right of what it could be and then
people will look
you know they will eventually make their
own decisions that they don't want
cow's milk in their cappuccino has
anybody come to the restaurant who
was not aware that you'd made this
switch to plant-based
and had some kind of problem
[Laughter]
as uh you know as a difficult
one-percenter could be
um no actually we we've been so blessed
with so many
excited guests i mean it's been and in a
way it's almost like wow really
like everyone is liking it because
sometimes when you push creativity
i'm sure as you know uh
to to a really great place it's not
universal
sure liked um but somehow this
experience somehow this has hit
a nerf um that was very timely
and and people are really responding
extremely positively
to this experience and even the people
who come in
uh with a lot of doubts we we definitely
had some people who
made the reservation before covet and
have paid before covet and we're
honoring their restoration now
but it's obviously a very different
restaurant yeah
and some of those come in with with a
lot of reservations but
i i i feel like people are really
really leaving with uh excitement it's
so cool man yeah
here's my theory let me know what you
think about this i think
that you are on this
spiritual journey towards
self-actualization
and deeper kind of integration
within yourself like you realize that
you
possess a certain level of talent a
certain level
of power and the pandemic has forced you
to
try to find deeper meaning in that and
you've come out with this
you know marvelous thing that you're
doing right now
and based upon kind of what you shared
last night about how you feel like you
feel lighter you feel more directed you
feel more creative like
there is something to that you know
mystical
energy of aligning
your gifts with something more
meaningful and purposeful
that you know creates a more authentic
being like a more self-integrated
individual
like and based upon what you were
sharing last night like this is
i see this transpiring in you and i
think it's just
i think you'll continue on this journey
i'm interested to see
where it goes but how do you think about
that like how do you think about it from
like
a broader more like mystical perspective
i know you're swiss you're
very precise and you know you
so i don't know what your relationship i
don't know
i don't know where you're going with
this but i kind of do you know you do
the thing is like that's what makes it
interesting being swiss
it must be confusing for you right
so i can't calibrate your watch to this
i know no
yeah no i definitely you know
after uh reaching the mountaintop of
becoming the best restaurant in the
world
you know at a pretty young age i
definitely ask myself
a lot of questions and i've done a lot
of soul searching
and i've tried all kinds of things to to
soul search
you know i went to india for two months
which was incredible and i felt um
you know it was challenging also
i don't know if you've been to india but
i haven't no but
it's an incredible place and a
challenging place and you feel
completely out of your comfort zone
um but it's it's extremely spiritual as
well
and and i've done uh i've done
a few psychedelic journeys as well yeah
and um
you know just searching um
for for more meaning and and for a
fuller version of myself
and uh i i think and and i hope it's
just gonna keep growing but
but today the work is definitely the
most meaningful yeah
and it and it feels like so many parts
of my life have
led to this very moment yeah you told me
last night that
you're almost quick to say that you're
not vegan yourself
um despite you know what you're doing in
the restaurant
and i think i said something like well
if you can if you can
uh you know dispense with that
you know disconnect like if you can
align your personal
lifestyle with what you're doing
professionally i think you'll see
an even greater kind of growth
or kind of celebration of what you're
doing but i think you'll also
feel more integrated and purposeful in
what you're doing
i think i think you're probably right
but the way i've always kind of let my
life is more out of
intuition rather than
so much about what i'm thinking
i should do more my gut feeling and i
think
this has all come from that place um
that i just felt like
this is the right thing to do and i
think my life just needs to catch up on
that's what i think i think i think it's
inevitable it's it's happening that
instinct that intuition will evolve as
well
it's it's absolutely happening i mean
even
um you know it would be strange for me
at this point to to to eat a plate of
meat
i haven't done it right and it's almost
the body is telling me
you know what the body's telling you
what what's actually good for you yeah
well what happens is as you continue to
evolve and grow
those things become less appealing and
they just fall away
effortlessly as opposed to like okay now
i'm going to try really hard to do this
thing it just becomes
incompatible with the way that you're
living yeah no and
you know and it's uh i i do believe in
two
talking things into existence um
when i have some big ideas i just start
talking about
even before i even fully comprehend what
what that means i mean to to make them
real
it does make him real but also
you know it's a really scary thing
change is scary for a lot of people
and i'm not in a you know i'm i'm in a
team sport
like there's a whole army uh to make
this happen every day and it's not just
what's in my head
but it's like i need to get everyone on
yeah i was on board
right like what happened when you told
your investors or
like this is what i'm going to do yeah
no here we go no there is so
our building we we have a lease in our
building
um and uh it's owned by two different
landlords
i think when they bought the building a
few years ago it's like a billion dollar
building or something like that
and they're 50 50 partners and one of
the partners reached out to the other
partner
when they heard about my decision and
they said well
do we have any say in this ask the
landlord of the building
um i mean oh my god it was hard yeah um
obviously yeah they don't but but people
really
it it's hard for people to to deal with
change
and and our team as well i mean it was
hard for
um our our team yeah to deal with this
yes big deal scary it's scary well you
don't get to
this point uh you know sitting atop the
the pinnacle of
of cuisine in the manner that you do
without being
competitive like behind your you know
very charming disposition
like there's got to be a killer in there
right like and you're
somebody who who was a very good athlete
like i'm interested let's go back
because the origin story is crazy with
you
growing up in a household where you had
a uh
you know a challenging difficult
relationship with your dad
your mom introducing you to food at a
young age but walk me through
what it was like growing up in
switzerland as a kid
yeah i i grew up with two um
as the youngest child to my parents who
were very young at that time
um my dad was going to architecture
school
[Music]
you know super detail detail-oriented
um but tough tough difficult dad
and nothing was ever good enough
and um you know it was hard and i think
to the point where you said earlier like
when when there is yelling
in the kitchen um you know there was
yelling at home sometimes
and and it was also because it was just
everything was overwhelming i mean my
dad was like
you know 21 years old and and there i
was
born and he was also going to
architecture school and
you know i i i think it was it's
difficult and
and uh it was uh
i started biking a lot at first i you're
a runner first right first i ran
and sport for me was sort of the outlet
i mean the more time i could be
out of the house the happier i was i
didn't really love school that much
but i started running and i started
running even as a young kid like for
miles and miles and months
and i competed in the um
in cross country and that gave me
the opportunity to travel around which
was really exciting when you're like 10
11 12 years old
um and uh you know i was running
i won the nationals two years in a row
and
at a very young age as a junior um but
then
and then even running wasn't even got me
far enough so then i started biking
because then i could even travel you
know your dad wasn't giving you the love
on the running
no love on the run no love no love on
the running
you know when you know i could come in
first
and his response would be
well the best guys were
injured or something like that you know
the guys who would have won were injured
uh it was never really um the winds
weren't really ever celebrated
it was hard man it's hard yeah it's hard
it's it's it is interesting that
you know i i didn't have that specific
experience but i did grow up
underneath a dad who set very high
expectations
for me that i couldn't ever seem to
quite you know
satisfy and i've had to do a lot of work
around that to make peace with it and i
love my dad and you know he did the best
he
he could and he's from a different
generation etc
um but i think there's something about
growing up with that kind of
um parenting or experiencing that kind
of trauma
that implants in you this
competitiveness like this drive
to excel because you so desperately want
to be recognized and seen
and i feel myself to this day still you
know i rely on that as a strength it can
also lead me astray
yeah but it is in some respect like a
superpower that rests within me because
that was born out of that type of
experience yeah
yeah that would be my my dad's response
to this how good it
you know right
so then you get on a bike and then it's
freedom i'm out of here i could be gone
like all day
yeah so i started erasing and i started
you know pretty much winning a lot of
races
um early and uh so i i had the
opportunity to leave school
at 14 years old to really uh become a
professional cyclist to be
part of it you know junior program for a
serious team
and um and for me it was like a
no-brainer i could leave
home and school it was like the greatest
right i wanted to do it and so
yeah that was amazing dad think about
that
oh it was so tough um he didn't think it
was a good idea at all but
somehow i got away with it and and i i
went for it
and that i did leave school at 14. so
that's the last formal schooling that
you had
yeah i went to school for eight years in
my life wow
and mom i mean she was crying
when i was leaving home you know because
my mom
i was very very close to her and she was
sort of like
magical and she cooked and um
spiritual as well like she's an artist
and
and for her it was just heartbreaking
for me to leave at that age but you know
looking back
it was the best decision it actually
suited me
um to go down this path are they still
around now
um yeah how's it going now well my mom
passed away unfortunately yeah but my
dad is around and
you know i have an okay relationship i
i think i agree um i i do love him too
and also he did the best he could
um but but it's hard to when when you
are not supported
at that age it's it's hard to ever fully
come
clear yeah yeah yeah it's tough so you
you leave home at 15.
yeah and that was it yeah gonna go be
a bicycle racer yeah what you did for
many years right
it's amazing yeah i got to see you know
all of
europe and um it taught me so
so so much and i would never be the chef
today
um if i didn't have that as as as a
background as an athlete you know like
there's so many setbacks and
you know it is so tough and so
competitive
and there's this romantic idea around
being a a cyclist a professional cyclist
but the reality is
so brutal there is no you're making no
money yeah you're living in
your belgium or something and racing in
the middle of the winter
and terrible weather and freezing all
the time
yeah you know eating ramen or whatever
barely making it enough to to scrape by
and always worried about getting cut
from the team right
getting cut from the team you know
injuries are all the time right crashes
injuries it's just
um yeah eventually i
i had a i had a bad accident
i was 22 years old and and um and that
kind of put everything in perspective
for me and i'm in a way
grateful to that accident um
because i was in the in the hospital
for weeks and and i realized that
this isn't going anywhere i i was not on
the path to be lance armstrong
and there were only like two or three
guys
on that level who actually made a living
yeah
from it and uh and that wasn't something
uh that was in the cards for me and you
know
[Music]
we also know about those times in
cycling
uh so it was just that kind of
environment that was very challenging
and difficult
and and it actually only worked for a
few
and and not even in the long run yeah i
mean you have these very interesting
inflection points throughout your life
that are all defined by these 180 pivots
that you make
from leaving home at 15 and saying i'm
not doing school anymore to
having the self-awareness as a young
person how old were you then 18 or 21 or
something like that
when you have that crash 21 21 right to
say
this is this is not going to work and
i'm going to completely
let it go that requires a certain
level of maturity you know to do that it
would have been easy to just keep going
and let it play out to its
you know inevitable conclusion but to
say i'm pulling out of this and i'm
going to go in a completely new
direction
i think i think that shows it's the same
thing when you decide to
make 11 madison park plant based like
these very
like hard line in the sand you know
switch ups
it's so liberating when you when you do
though
and it comes when i moved to america i
moved to america when i was 25 and i
just left it was kind of the same
similar moment
where i just left everything behind and
i came with two suitcases and i barely
spoke the language
but it is such a liberating feeling
to know that everything you need is
inside of you
you don't need anything else and
i mean only covet could have given me
this experience
again so late you know late in life
at 44 years old where
i was literally sitting in my apartment
a year ago
not knowing if i'm gonna have a
restaurant not knowing how to
pay for the bills for the business and
and coming to terms with
the idea i might lose it all
and it's okay and when you get to that
place and and i hope i can
i hope i don't need to get physically to
that place
you know again but i hope mentally i
i can get myself into that space uh for
many many years to come because in that
space
you're very free and you're able to make
pretty bold
moves uh without fear right but you did
your
your work like you've been doing
push-ups all along right like you've
made these pivots in the past
you've taken these risks it's worked out
for better
or worse each time so when it comes to
you know making this big more recent
decision that you've made
you already have that life experience of
knowing
like this is the only way because this
is the way i've always done it
yeah and somehow it always works out
maybe not in the
manner in which i imagine or on the
timetable but
short of doing that you rob yourself of
the magic that can transpire by you know
deciding to incur that kind of risk yeah
i think it only always works out
not because there is this you know
success that's by your audience but it's
the success that you do what's in your
heart
and that's why it works out like when
you do what's in your heart
then it's the right decision it doesn't
matter if it's critically successful or
not
but if you continue to follow your heart
i believe that gives you freedom and
that
you know yeah so in the wake of the
bicycle accident at 21
walk me through the introduction to food
and that becoming
like your your path well as you said
as a cyclist you don't make a lot of
money and i didn't either
and so actually at 15
when i decided to go
pursue cycling as a profession
my dad said okay you can do this but you
have to move out i'm not supporting this
and i said okay um not even fully
understanding what that meant but
you know i had to get a job so when i
was in training or traveling for races
i had to find a job and the only place i
could get a job was in a kitchen
at 15 years old and i was really lucky
that i found
a place with a chef that became my
mentor
and it wasn't just a job but he took it
on him to teach me and comes like a
father
figure he was like a father figure and
by the time the accident happened
i've actually already cooked for six
years
and my mom was an excellent cook
and even more so she
she she really put a lot of value on the
ingredients
like we got all of our vegetables from
the farm
every everything from the farm like
fresh milk every day she would bake her
own breads
we would pick our own salads in the
fields and
and so you know as a kid that was
annoying but
because so much work to prepare the meal
but it gave me this understanding of
what a great ingredient was so in a way
i was
set up for it without even knowing i
never thought i would
pursue cooking as a career but when i
was in the hospital
[Music]
and i thought about the cycling i
actually didn't like cycling as much
anymore
it just became something so different it
became so
so so competitive and
it wasn't enjoyable and when i thought
about where i found pleasure
was when i thought of the moments in the
kitchen
and then i thought well i should just do
that and if i can't become
the best cyclist in the world
maybe i can become one of the best chefs
was that a very concrete decision that
you made like do you have awareness that
you were making that kind of pivot
and refocusing all of your
intentionality into this okay
okay i was all in on cycling now i'm
going all in on this
yeah this this happened in one day wow
this was one moment
when i made that decision and then
um one of my
trainers was close to this restaurant
that had three stars
i was in the french part of switzerland
and we ate there once
after a race and it was so magical like
we
we sat in that kitchen and
that was actually the first time i saw
cooking
on on this level that was actually that
kind of planted the seed
that cooking could be a sport or
a career but we were sitting in the
middle of this
three michele star restaurant uh it was
called freddy's cheer day
and uh they were like 25 chefs
working all around us like similar to
what you saw
last night at our restaurant but
everyone had perfect starched
uniforms and big tokes the hats
and they were serving us the most
incredible
meal and and they were working in
harmony and it was like
watching a ballet and sort of that
planted a seed
and uh yeah i was in the hospital
and i called my coach and i said
do you remember that dinner we had two
years ago
can you call that guy i want to work
there
and he said what he's like well
i don't want to race anymore bearing the
lead and he did it
and he did and three months later i had
a job
wow wow and is that the restaurant what
was the restaurant that you were
working in when you had the
the accident on route to the farmer's
market at like three in the morning
that was later that was late um that was
a few years later
um i was working in this little
restaurant that was actually my
first place where i was the chef and
i was 25 years old and i would go to the
market every morning
to zurich it was an hour away and this
was in a mountain town
and one morning there was so much snow
and
i was so tired probably slept four hours
and i got up at five in the morning to
drive to zurich and
yeah and the car just went out of
control and and
i was sliding down this you know
hill and i hit a tree and i was super
lucky that there was a tree
um right because short of you angled the
car towards the little twig of a tree
because short of that you were looking
at an alpine cliff that it would have
certainly meant your death yeah it would
have killed me wow
and then i called the farmer of this
place and he came with the tractor and
he pulled me out
right like the thing being like man i
need to reassess my priorities instead
you're like i gotta get to the farmer's
market because the restaurant can't
operate unless i get there and get the
stuff
like the level of obsession
at that moment in your life layered on
top of which you've got a very
complicated personal situation you
you had a kid at 18 right like you had a
an older girlfriend who then
left you which you know the pain of that
forces you to just go
all in on career i won't be hurt nobody
can abandon me this is the one thing
that i can control and just
literally becoming obsessed yeah no
that's right yeah
it's not always healthy but um
it definitely um pushes you it
definitely um
[Music]
yeah you know you you have to push
yourself to extreme levels to reach
the success and and that's what you
learn in sports
right it's 100 not who is the most
talented
is like who who can hurt the most
actually well especially in cycling
yeah because nothing there's no sort of
self-inflicted suffering can be
experienced
like it can be on a bike yeah yeah and
you learn that right
but this then gets channeled into
this discussion around passion like we
live in a culture it's like chase your
passion
we should all live passionate lives and
what i love about
the way that you think about this is
is the fact that it's filtered through
the german definition of passion this
idea of
leiden shaft so explain that because i
think it's really
profound and it's so much of a better
way to think about this type of
lifestyle
yeah no in in german uh the word passion
is leiden soft and
and leiden is actually suffering and uh
and and chuffed is sort of like in
enduring
you know endure suffering or or being
willing to suffer for something
because that's really passion otherwise
it's just like a hobby
but if you're passionate about something
you know are you willing to suffer for
it mm-hmm
um yeah exactly and the suffering will
will inevitably come it will be visited
upon you
as you know because doing anything
well is [ __ ] hard and if you want to
be at the highest level
prepare yourself like there just aren't
that many people who are willing to kind
of endure
what it's going to take to get to the
you know the peak whether it's in
cycling or running or being a chef or
any other goal or dream that you're
chasing
that's just the truth but it's you know
it's the journey
that is beautiful and and there is
suffering but there's also so many
beautiful parts and and the moments of
suffering make
the beautiful moment sure so you can't
have one without the that's exactly
right you know you can't
and and even with that like when you
were talking about
reaching number one and you think oh
i've been
vying for this for a decade and then it
gets there and it's
you find it lacking in the satisfaction
that you were expecting and that's
always the case right because
the value is in the endeavor it's in the
getting there
it's in the journey undertaken it's in
the hardship and the struggle and the
suffering
the you know leiden shaft that is packed
into
trying to you know aspiring to that
place yeah it's not the arrival the
arrival
is a footnote the journey is over
kind of when you're right and and then
you're there and you're like now what
yeah
right yeah like that's a scary place to
be yeah
short of you figuring this out for
yourself
like short of covid kind of compelling
this introspection on your level
it would have been interesting to see
what would have happened it was
difficult
like i know covet has been devastating
and
and obviously super painful for a lot of
people and a lot of loss and it's
devastating but in in my case
it's it's really i found a lot of
positive
in it and before you know now
before i was this chef that was
named number one at some point and you
know the reservations were booked and
booked and booked and booked and
and i became more more of a brand than
than a person and
so many of my partners wanted to
monetize this brand
you know people saw opportunities um
to open different concepts
you know casual concepts alignment with
brands
and all this kind of stuff and and i
started
completely losing myself i i wasn't even
in charge of my own schedule in a way
anymore it was just like
i was this you know face of this brand
that you know that
a lot of people were interested in but i
wasn't
and so it was really challenging and
when everything fell apart
during covet i was really able to
cut ties with you know a lot of
organizations a lot of partners a lot of
projects
yeah in a way that i don't know if it
would have been possible yeah
i mean you know your entrepreneurial
journey is fascinating
as this hybrid of of how do you blend
art and commerce in a way that is
successful it's a
you know it's a difficult recipe to get
correct you've had all of these
successes along the way and all these
different
kind of incarnations of partnerships
from you know danny meyer originally
bringing you into 11 madison park in
in in the first place and then you and
will guidara is that how you say his
last name um kind of purchasing or danny
selling you
the restaurant and then you having this
partner and this fruitful partnership
with this guy in which you
create all of these amazing
opportunities but ultimately
your life scales out of control right
you become a brand you become a
licensing vehicle
yeah and then to cut ties with all of
that
and narrow you know your focus to just
literally this one
like let go of the hotels and all the
kind of stuff yeah just say i want to
get back to the one thing that i
that i love that gives me creative
sustenance
is a bold move in and of itself and now
here you are
like you have investors but essentially
you're the proprietor and sole
you know owner of this restaurant you've
got one in london as well but
to have the the kind of sensibility to
say
bigger isn't necessarily better it's
moving me away from
what i'm actually seeking yeah
you know what's interesting is that all
[Music]
associations partnerships in in my case
i think
or most of all were were actually
needed and beneficial and and it got me
to this point
i mean it's it starts with even just in
a restaurant when you think about
the need for guests in the beginning you
need to kind of
cook the food that guests will want and
will
pay for and then only slowly you can
kind of
come into your own and you can add some
creativity to it and i tell you what you
like
yeah right
i mean a little bit i don't know what
they want that's my job
but we we are still doing it today i
mean today we're cooking completely
plant-based
people don't even want you know know
that they would like that but
but the meal starts with this you know
essence of tomato
right this simple tea of tomato
that is sort of like disarming
and no matter who you are you're shy
you're shocking people into you're
giving them the sense like this is
going to be unlike what you expect it to
be like i when
it's placed down in front of you there's
no explanation of what it is
yeah i thought oh this is a tea or we're
going to cleanse our palate and get
ready and then you take one sip and
you're like whoa
i've never had anything like that before
certainly you taste the tomato but
clearly it's a distillation of i don't
know how many thousands of
tomatoes are compressed to get like that
density of flavor into this clear broth
yes and inevitably you think okay this
is going to be a ride like
no other it's intentionally very
simple easy to digest and very very
delicious
universal delicious and so it's
then then we can take people on a
journey then they're like
it's kind of like a hug it's like it's
going to be a dress meal i trust
exactly yeah and that's with the cooking
and that's with partnerships like i've
needed
certain partners to understand how
business works in america i
had no idea i came from switzerland i
left school at 14.
you know and now i'm running an empire
here in new york city i mean it really
is [ __ ] crazy you know i needed
these uh steps if you will
um but um you know if you get to the
place
and and proudly i can say i don't have
an investor
anymore and and it took years wow i'm 44
years old and you're the sole owner
yeah i could have this decision to go
plant-based
i don't think i don't know if there's an
investor out there
who would have said oh this is a great
idea we just had covet
now go plant-based you know
i don't know if that right investor is
out there
that's liberating that's liberating you
know you got landlords and all that but
yeah you know
wow no it's pretty cool what is
in your mind the distinction between
good and great with food like there are
plenty of good chefs
what goes into being a great chef for
people that
aren't steeped in you know this type of
this world this subculture
like how do you think about that that's
a big question
i i think you know foremost it's uh
i think cooking is is a craft and
you know i think there are amazing
amazing restaurants
um where you just go and have an amazing
meal with amazing sourced ingredients
prepared in a beautiful way
and then in in in rare cases
it kind of can transcend that
and and it it can actually add something
i talked about culture earlier how fine
dining is
is a big part of culture and and and the
language of sorts
like you know we know that
there are a lot of different languages
that the languages of politics and the
languages of art and different kinds of
arts and
i think there's a language of food and i
think chefs through history of time have
you know when you think of alice waters
i don't know it's in the 70s probably
when she
you know really made a big
stand on local food that was
groundbreaking and
and it was um it really changed culture
it changed
it changed america and and there's been
other chefs
you know in the history of time before
so i think very rarely there's
someone that comes along and that really
can make
that kind of that kind of impact is it
an intangible like i know it when i
taste it or see it or feel it or
are there criteria like when you sit
down at a restaurant and you're
surprised and you're like
this is great and this is great because
xyz like can it be distilled down
into variables that you feel are
important ingredients in making it
making a proclamation that a certain
chef or a certain restaurant
you know stands or sits above its
competitors
to me it's like when it's bigger than
the restaurant
to me it's there is the craft and
when you're in a restaurant of great
craftsmen and great chefs
then you're in the restaurant and you
taste it and you see the
attention to detail and the way the
flavors are balanced
and it's harmonious and all that and
then there are a few restaurants
where it's bigger than the restaurant
where it's
about something bigger and you and
that's just the feeling
and that's just when it's like almost
like it's some kunstwerk
where everything is from
the place to the people to the education
of the people
to the plate where to where it's
this one idea of a gizamcon and then it
can really um
make a real big impact that will trickle
down to all kinds of industries
yeah there's the you know hero dreams of
sushi type
mastery and then there's the kind of
orchestration
of scaling up that mastery to cultivate
an extraordinary experience yeah right
yeah
it's interesting it's something that
i think you know to kind of pivot back
to the mystical a little bit
there's a saying i was talking to jeff
about this last night
i'm long time in recovery and there's an
adage in alcoholics anonymous that
you you can't transmit something you
haven't got like you have to carry the
vibration within you
to be the lighthouse that will attract
the energy into your life
that you aspire to have right you can't
fake that like you're either living it
and you're being it
or you're a pretender and increasingly i
think people their antennae for like
what is real and what is authentic
has never been more finely honed like we
can all see [ __ ] coming
a million miles away and we can all
identify
when something is real or something is
different
or carrying that vibration that we want
to be
around you know and i think the more
that you instill that
in yourself and in the culture that you
create in your kitchen
you know the more that that will
resonate out into the world and attract
those kind of people
into this mission that you're on of you
know transforming food insecurity
i think that's really well said and i
think
i think so true i think authenticity
you you feel if it's authentic or not
yeah and i think you know
the one thing i do believe though is
that if if you do not
perfect the craft you will never get
your
yeah it's lost right to the next and you
can't there's a lot of people who
break rules but they they never took the
time to master the craft itself and
really understand the rules like you
can't
paint outside the lines until you really
know how to paint
you know with mastery within the lines
yeah that's why
you know art is such a great inspiration
to me and
and uh i you know most of my friends are
are
painters or sculptures or dancers
and um it it is so interesting when you
follow for example mondrian
most people know you know mondrian one
of the first
abstract painters um but when you look
at his early paintings
they weren't abstract at all they were
landscapes and
and and beautiful ones but then at some
point he
became montreal right it's always
amazing to see
early works of some of those more modern
artists who are doing
radically different things and to
realize like oh they actually they can
do it the other way yeah
that's right that's making it brilliant
right right
well art has been so
crucial and influential in how you think
about food and just the restaurant
experience in general so talk a little
bit about
that influence and also how it's kind of
informed some of these pivots
you know specifically going from
this very um i wouldn't say
sensory overload experience but you know
kind of a robust sensory experience to
trimming things down into a more
minimalistic
approach i've heard you talk about
minimalism before i would characterize
it more as
essentialism like getting rid of
anything that's
not informing you know the experience or
the art that you're trying to share
yeah i think that's really good
observation i
i actually called elemental like where
everything is there that's needed but
nothing right nothing
is nothing extraneous yes for me
when i was 12 years old i had my first
real experience with art and my parents
took me to the lingerie in paris and
you know that's where it's the museum
where
they hold the the large monet water lily
paintings and it's sort of these two
oval rooms of just mooney water lilies
and as a 12 year old kid
you just feel like you're totally
wrapped into these paintings
and for the first time i had this
experience when i
i didn't know how i was feeling did it
was i happy was i
sad it was really bizarre i was like
very emotional
and since then i knew that art was
speaking to me and was really
important to me and i think
forever since then i've wherever i go
i visit artists studios i go to museums
i go to galleries
and i read about art and i think
i had another really meaningful
experience and that was probably at the
age of like 24
when i saw for the first time i saw
lucio fontana
these paintings where he it's just a
canvas a white canvas and he took a
knife and he just cuts through the
canvas
and a friend of mine took me to see that
show and said hey
this is a really important artist and
you should
you know really dig in on him
and i didn't really understand like what
the [ __ ] is this exactly
he literally took a knife and slashed
the middle of a white canvas
but my friend was very knowledgeable so
i trusted him and
and you know in the next few weeks i i
tried to understand
why this painting was so important and
it's exactly to the point that you said
it because he was
fontana was well a great sculptor
he worked in ceramics but he could also
paint anything
i mean he was just a really accomplished
artist and at some point he decided that
he would just cut the canvas and that's
his master
piece and that painting in fact
changed art forever because with that
one
slid in the canvas he questioned
everything that sort of was there before
like
does a canvas need to have a painting is
art on the canvas
could the canvas be the art could the
artwork be
behind the canvas i mean he questions
everything is painting sculpture
or is the art the conversation around
the work itself yeah as well yeah
so taking that like what do you make of
that for yourself like why was that so
impactful to you and how does that get
channeled into how you think about
food and the experiences that you're
providing
the more i thought about that work was
he changed art forever with a very
minimal gesture and for me that was just
so
powerful and so mind-blowing and so
this is how i wanted to cook i wanted to
cook
very minimal but say a lot
and i realized that that was a lot
harder
than than it seemed because
the gesture has to be so strong and
there is nowhere to hide and as a young
chef
often i had two ingredients on the plate
and i was like uh that's not a complete
dish
no one would think that's great so then
i added things
i said oh it needs another puree another
ingredient another
texture and it became more complicated
but at that point you know guests were
reacting to this
more than they would have with two
ingredients on the plate
and it took a long time for me to get to
the place
where i could have two ingredients on
the place and it probably only happened
um like four years ago right in the way
that
was it alice waters who would just say
here's two dates
on a plate that's it it takes a lot to
get there
it takes a certain level of audacity
confidence yeah
yeah but you're not lacking in
confidence well thank you
i don't know if that's a compliment you
know um
but on this no i mean it it
it's i guess you know courage is
probably a better word
like to say i have you know a strong
enough sense of self and what i'm doing
that i can put this out there and maybe
not be certain but have some level of
confidence that it will be
received because it's backed up by this
lifetime of experience and this trust
that you've engendered over time
is that accurate how does that one feel
i just backed myself into a corner
you know it it takes a long time
to um you know be very
simple yeah yeah yeah and and that's
reflected in the
in the the rita ackerman painting in the
restaurant right the chalkboard
painting that's very stripped down
that's on
one far side of the wall hanging hanging
high up
that kind of to me symbolizes like
we can always erase this and start fresh
or new like nothing is permanent
it's a reminder like this is a process
yeah it's like uh picasso said
you know a painting is uh
it's never finished it's only abandoned
yeah and i think that's true
that's true of everything that's right
whether you're writing a book or
you know preparing meals i mean the the
difference with cuisine
yes there's this constant every day
you're doing it it's evolving it's an
organic living breathing thing
but each meal in and of itself is almost
like
a zen mandala because it will be
consumed and destroyed
yeah well it's hard permanent yeah it is
impermanent
and and you know there's an artist
called andy goldsworthy which were very
inspired by
and he works in nature a lot and and uh
he he makes like sculptures out of
icicles and
you know he builds them and then the sun
comes right
and they're gone and they're gone or he
ties these leaves together and he lets
them run down the river
and it's so beautiful but it's
impermanent
um it's hard to it's
beautiful because i think a lot in life
the impermanent things make it magical
um but as a as a creator it's also
difficult because
you know you had dinner there last night
yeah
and uh there's someone else going to
have dinner there tonight
and and we have to recreate that moment
over and over and over again yeah do you
think about
the kind of mystical aspect of like
putting
things inside of people's bodies like
i've created this thing
it carries a certain vibration a certain
vitality
other people are consuming that and then
they're going out into the world
this sort of diaspora of human beings
who are carrying that vibration i mean
jeff was talking
last night about the first time he ate
at the restaurant and
you know as a longtime food critic and
writer he's used to going to these
restaurants and they kind of just give
him a million dishes and he rolls out of
there and he feels like [ __ ]
you know even though the food is
wonderful but in the case of
11 madison park with the new menu
feeling like
vital and elevated for he said like a
couple days
you know even though he's not like he
wouldn't consider himself plant-based i
think he's you know playing around with
that in his idea but there is something
to that idea of
of you are providing a certain
wavelength of energy
and putting it into other people's
bodies and that has like
that activates people and puts them on
their own kind of journey of exploration
their own like trajectory of like
learning and exploring and growing and
evolving
yeah i mean it's it's uh humbling to
to know that you know what we're
creating
and people are are eating ingestion
and uh i think there is it's really
interesting
even beyond our knowledge of what's
actually happening
um during this meal like we it's
it's a fully plant-based meal but
we're working a lot more with with
different cultures and that
actually you know when we talk about
removing a lot of ingredients
of animals the one ingredient that came
up a lot was the ingredient of time
like the time it takes to ferment
something or
you know we're working on all kinds of
different fermentations of sauces
and choyus and you know you get a like a
soy sauce it's like
gives you an idea but there there are so
many
it's endless it's endless what you can
do
not from soy but from so many other
things
and when we removed meat
we felt like we wanted to
um still have
a meal that is balanced of like where
there are some dishes are more light
some dishes are more i'm going to use
the word
meaty but richer and so umami
is definitely very central in this
cooking we also worked with these
buddhist monks who are
cooking a cuisine called trojan and
we learned about the ingredient of time
we learned about
using different cultures in different uh
dishes like
cultures like like from uh
yeah different uh you know we have we're
working with a lab called kingdom
culture who
they have a library of cultures from
around the world from like sauerkraut
or kimchi or cultures you you mean not
populations of people you mean literal
like biological cultures
right yeah thank you yeah and
and i think it affects people i think
during a meal having
eating these biological cultures
uh is affecting people almost to a place
where people feel
euphoric in a beautiful way yeah and i
think that's what jeff is
is sort of talking about and we don't
even fully understand
i think michael pollan said that you
know
we know the body so well uh many parts
of the body we know so well but actually
what's happening in our gut our our
knowledge
is is so limited right it's like um
so i think there there's a lot of work
that's still yeah it's
gonna happen yeah it is this uh amazing
amalgam of all these different
influences and cultures you mentioned
um the japanese tradition buddhist
temple food
ideas from india china nouvelle cuisine
from france
yeah in the 70s boule patterson
passard like all of these influences
being kind of hybridized and
um uniquely uh kind of
through your you know unique perspective
creating something new out of all of
that
the host last night was um sharing about
the the grinding of the the uh the
sesame seeds every day
yeah and how that's almost become it's
like a team activity right but it's
almost like a group
meditation that begins every day with
this laborious process
oh it's amazing yeah
and like how about like the people that
have to chop the
the cucumber and the daikon yeah that
one dish
they spend all day just doing that right
for that one
dish yeah it's extremely labor intensive
but there's something about that that's
beautiful it's like so much
heart is required to do that you know
when you take it in
there is some i think there is something
intangible about
like that that is impactful one
one of um the buddhist monks
who was with us for for this last year
in new york uh his name is toshio
and he said he thinks that we should
have the guests
also grand session before their meetings
should yes
yes here this is going to cost you an
arm and a leg now go in the back room
because you can't appreciate how could
you possibly truly appreciate
what has gone into this unless you're
actually doing some part of it
right but but you know i mean it's a
it's a wild idea but
when you the the sesame grounding
is is central to the cooking
uh the sand boot is cooking and you
literally
sit on a floor on your knee for an hour
and you're with this wooden petal and
you're grinding
the sesame seeds counterclockwise
because on this side of the earth
everything in nature goes
counterclockwise
and first of all it's really painful to
sit for an hour on your knees
like almost unbearable it's unbearable
the first few times you do it and then
it becomes sort of bearable
and then to grind for an hour by hand
it's hard
and i it's this meditation that's all
it's like passion yeah yeah you know
you really have to uh work for it
but then when you're done you're in a
different mindset
and i think that's his point of having
the guest participate
right right that's the palette cleanser
that's the required
preparation to put you in the state of
mind to receive
that's right appropriately wow um we got
to wrap this up because i know you got
to go in a minute here but i i think a
good place to kind of
close it is to talk a little bit about
the new york of your imagination like
if you can continue to scale rethink
and you start getting more invested
in the communities that require food
assistance like how can this
transform this city and set an example
for
you know the rest of the country in the
world because
basically what happens in new york like
then percolates out like new york is the
place from which
culture emanates in so many ways and you
have this opportunity
that you're taking advantage of to lead
by example
so how does this you know how would you
like
the world to perceive this and how can
people or restaurateurs or chefs or
cooks who are
tuning in for this start being part of
this solution as well
well i think the one thing to remember
is that
you know sometimes you get when you hear
the numbers of food insecure people
in new york or america the number is so
big
that you often feel like wow
i'm i'm not able to make a difference
here what difference does that make like
the number of food insecure new yorkers
during the pandemic was 2 million 2
million people a day
and so we cooked 5 000 meals
a day which is a lot of meals just
imagine the amount of boxes
trucks everything five thousand compared
to two million it's nothing
so on some days i was like wow
we're never going to make a dent into
this but then
when you go into these neighborhoods and
you're actually
giving the meals away you're realizing
that
every single drop matters and
every meal matters and so
i think that's not a drop to them it's
not a drop to them
and i think that's when if everyone out
there
does what they can the smallest thing
matters
and in their community there are amazing
organizations all over and they're
always
looking yeah for help yeah yeah i mean
there are there are plenty of other
organizations out there that are doing
you know this kind of work i just had
maggie baird on the podcast who's billy
eilish's mom she's got an organization
called support and feed she's doing
essentially
the same thing yeah jayden smith in la
has his i love you truck he goes down to
skid row and he delivers plant-based
meals amazing but i feel like the power
of rethink
is to create these organizational tools
to
establish efficiencies in communication
and distribution so that
all of the various people who are doing
good work can
align in a certain way that can you know
establish the kind of scale required to
address the problem
you know in a macro meaningful way i
think using the infrastructure that
already exists
is probably the most powerful way we can
actually uh make a difference and and in
particular
if we can even uh make the
infrastructure stronger
because there are already funds a lot of
funds going towards
food insecurity but a lot of the systems
are so antiquated right
some of these food banks and where the
money goes to it's just so antiquated
so i think that has to be rethought too
where the money flows and and and using
the existing
infrastructure that can strengthen it
yeah good man
well i appreciate your time thank you
pleasure talking to you
i could go for two more hours there's
other things i want to talk to you about
your daily routine
and what your exercise looks like i got
lots of so
maybe at some point you can indulge me
by a part two to this but i really
appreciate you taking the time to do
this no i really
appreciate you i really appreciate it um
what you're doing is is meaningful it's
important i was
personally very impacted by my
experience last night and
if there's anything i can do to help you
i am at your service my friend
thank you i really appreciate it
likewise
once again i want to thank joe at
newstand studios here at rockefeller
center for providing the space for us to
have this conversation
you can follow them at rockefeller
center on instagram or
at rockcenternyc on twitter
and uh until next time my friend you got
to get to the restaurant probably
right i do yeah yeah starting yeah
you're pretty mellow considering like
you have to put on this crazy show every
night
it's wild yeah um thank you thank you so
much peace
plants peace yes
[Music]
thanks for listening everybody for links
and resources related to everything
discussed today
visit the show notes on the episode page
at richroll.com
if you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing
you can do is to subscribe to the show
on apple podcasts
on spotify and on youtube sharing the
show or your favorite episode with
friends or on social media is of course
always appreciated
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects
subscribe to our newsletter which you
can find on the footer of any page
on richroll.com today's show was
produced and engineered by jason camiolo
the video edition of the podcast was
created by blake curtis
portraits by ally rogers and davey
greenberg graphic elements courtesy of
jessica miranda
copywriting by georgia whaley and our
theme music was created by tyler piatt
trapper piatt and harry mathis you can
find me
at richroll.com or on instagram and
twitter
rich roll i appreciate the love i love
the support
i don't take your attention for granted
thank you for listening
see you back here soon peace plants
[Music]
you